handcrafted items perhaps once of some
sentimental value
among clothes and toys that still have
their tags on
all of them have got the labels on i'm
really shocked by the generosity of
people and we have some shoes here
brand new designer shoes i think they're
worth up to 175 pounds
in manchester five storage units plus a
warehouse are overflowing with donations
we've been at this now for three days
we've had just over a hundred volunteers
with more to come just to help get
through the mountain of amazing
donations we've had
items that are no longer of use to their
previous owners can be essential to
refugees arriving in the uk
like tassal danish who fled afghanistan
with his wife and four young children
all they have of the life they left
behind
are these videos tassal made just before
they escaped
the condition was so bad you know and i
didn't bring anything with me
just like him with uh with a shirt you
know
with the
other stuff for the children
they left everything behind but they
really missed their my parents you know
their grandfather
grandma
and
some of their school colleagues you know
and
some of their friends too
the children now play in a hotel car
park
in hertfordshire rabbi elhanon feldman
has had to put this sign up after his
synagogue became overwhelmed by
donations
people have come with their cars filled
with provisions with high quality goods
that they've collected personally from
their own family and friends from their
own temples from their own churches from
their own mosques so people are coming
representing so many others who were not
able to come it's just been absolutely
outstanding to see the spirit
donations have now spilled over into
people's houses
mountains of discarded clothes and
objects set aside to help new arrivals
get a fresh start sadia chowdhury sky
news